This is pre-Katniss.
-Set 64 years in the past.
It's been 10 years
since the districts
and The Capitol
have, like, gone to war.
And the Hunger Games have been
going on for 10 years.
-It's a giant,
giant, giant movie.
♪♪
Viola Davis,
welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
Every time someone stands up,
I'm like,
"Do you really know who I am?"
-Yes! Absolutely!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you! Come on.
-I'll accept it.
-Last time you were
on our show --
I feel like
we're good luck together,
'cause last time
you were on the show,
you were promoting
"The Woman King."
-Yes.
-And you were like, "Jimmy,
I worked so hard
on this thing."
Backstage. And you're like,
"I'm just nervous.
I'm excited about this.
I think it's a great movie.
I want people to go out there
and see it."
And not only did people
go out and see it,
it was the number-1 movie
and then one of
the best films of 2022.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Viola Davis crushed it!
You were awesome!
-Thank you, thank you.
-You were awesome!
-I was the O.G. warrior.
-You were fantastic.
That was great.
And then, since I've seen you,
you won a Grammy Award,
and -- I know, but --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Come on.
For a recording of
the audiobook of your
number-1 best-selling book,
"Finding Me."
-Yes.
-Come on.
This is -- It's all happening.
It's all happening.
But then it put you
in EGOT status.
-Yes.
-Emmy, Grammy, Oscar, Tony --
EGOT.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think I can retire now.
-Never! Don't you ever retire.
Are you kidding me? We need you.
-Why not? Why can't I retire?
-Never.
-I can do whatever I want.
-No!
-I'm an EGOT.
-I know.
[ Laughs ] Exactly.
Did it -- How does it feel?
Are you excited?
Do you even look at it
and process it yet?
-No, I don't look at it.
-You don't.
-I don't --
-I would.
-You know what? That's a lie.
I just told a bold-faced lie
on national television.
-You look at all of them?
-No, as soon as I got
that Grammy in the mail,
I put that Grammy, that Tony,
that Oscar, that Emmy,
and I took a fabulous picture.
-That's exactly -- Yes!
Something. You got to enjoy it
because you earned it
and you got it.
-That's right.
-That is so cool.
Maybe next time you come on,
maybe I can --
We could see
if you can bring it with you.
But that's a lot of awards.
-No, I'm not going to do that.
-I know. Yeah, I know.
I understand, I understand.
I want to talk to you about
the new "Hunger Games" movie.
-Yes.
-This comes out --
We can talk about movies.
-Okay.
-Actors can talk about movies.
-Finally!
-Yes! It feels great.
Look at you, by the way.
Look at Viola Davis.
-Yeah, uh-huh.
-Look at this. Can we...
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Hunger Games: The Ballad
of Songbirds and Snakes."
This is the origin story.
-This is the origin story.
I feel like every character
I do now
is an homage to my childhood,
which means that I don't want
anyone messing with me.
I want to kick people's ass.
-What are you talking --
What are you talking about?
That's --
-I mean,
it's like a villain in this,
a warrior in "Woman King."
You know, everything is about,
"I'm gonna kick somebody's ass!"
-This is different sides
of you that we like to --
Do you like playing the villain?
-Oh, I love
playing the villain
because everybody sees me.
Everybody wants to hug me.
Everybody wants to kiss me.
There are grown men
who want to kiss me
in the parking lot of Target.
You know, they want to --
they want to hold me.
And literally, they come up to
me and I'm thinking,
"Okay, they're going to ask me
for an autograph or whatever."
Sometimes, they have tears
in their eyes,
and they're like,
"Can I hug you?"
-Yeah.
-You know, almost like
they have to reconcile
a bad childhood or something.
And I always hug them.
-You do?
But now --
But those days are over.
Those days are over now.
-No, I'm still gonna
hug them,
because, you know, really,
really, at the end of the day,
I like when people
stand up for me.
-Yeah, I know you do.
Yeah, I know you love it.
But I like that you play
different roles
and you could play
whatever you want to do.
And this looks like fun to me.
-And we shot it in Berlin.
And let me tell you something --
It -- I'll tell you --
my experience in Berlin
can be summed up in one thing.
When I came back to Los Angeles,
my triglycerides were high.
-Okay.
-That was my experience
in Berlin.
-Just ate.
-I ate, I drank.
I got in that Jacuzzi every day.
And let me tell you something,
I love a Jacuzzi.
And when I got
in that Jacuzzi --
my $10 bathing suit -- I got
in that Jacuzzi every night.
I was invited to the opera by
random strangers in the Jacuzzi.
-Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
-I was invited to dinner from
random strangers in the Jacuzzi.
I got a whole skin line --
skincare line from someone
who sat in the Jacuzzi.
They recognized me and said,
"Oh, you know what?
I have a whole skincare line
that I want to give you."
-Wait, no. Viola Davis,
I have to ask you this question.
I'm sorry. Rewind.
We missed a big thing here.
You went to, like,
a public Jacuzzi?
-That's all you got
from that story?
-Yes.
You won every award you can.
-What other Jacuzzi
am I going to go to?
-I thought maybe you had
a private Jacuzzi.
I wouldn't --
You went to, like, a --
-Well, you need to call
the producers
of "Hunger Games" about that.
I did not have the suite
with the private Jacuzzi.
-So, it's a hotel,
and you're at the hotel Jacuzzi.
-Listen, I looked at the back
of a hairy man's red ass.
-What is going on?
What is going on at this hotel?
-Yes.
-But you went back.
-I went back.
Listen, I got a skincare line.
I got invited to the opera.
I got invited to dinner.
I was -- And, literally,
I would tell my friends
Jamika and Sergio --
I was like,
"You want to come
to Jacuzzi with me?
I got invited to the opera.
We have a skincare line.
You don't want to look
at the back of that man's ass."
-No, no, no.
But you always have
the memories.
-Yes.
-But that's insane
that you would do that.
Did people freak out
and go like,
"I'm in a Jacuzzi
with Viola Davis"?
-No, I don't --
Here's the thing.
I'm just going to say it.
I got to show my I.D. a lot.
There's not a lot of people
who recognize me.
Well, there was some times
they recognize me.
Sometimes, they think I'm Oprah.
They think I'm Alfre Woodard.
You know, they think
I'm Taraji P. Henson,
which really baffles me.
-Wow!
-You know?
-That's insane.
I just love that you do that.
-Yes, absolutely.
You work out in the gym.
Walked in the park in Germany
late at night
with all my friends.
And as soon as
it got really dark,
I'm thinking, "Oh, my God.
It is dark.
It's in the park.
Somebody's going to get us."
-Yeah.
-I walked in that park
with a straight up tree limb.
-As a weapon?
-As a weapon.
-What is going on at this hotel?
-I live my best life.
-You never had to use
the tree limb, though, did you?
Yeah, maybe? Okay.
Alright, alright.
-I would never say
if I used a tree limb.
-Is this because of all these
action movies
that you're doing now?
You're getting
this new Viola Davis?
-Yeah, I think so.
And, you know, the the makeup in
"Hunger Games" took four hours.
-I know. That's what
I was saying.
Could we zoom in?
-Four hours.
And then it took maybe
45 minutes to take it off.
And the hardest part to take off
was the nose.
I mean, it was so hard
that the makeup artists
literally had to brace
their feet and just pull it.
It was like an anal probe.
It was like --
I mean, stretching it.
-What?!
-You have no idea.
I said -- It was like -- I mean,
plastic that was coming out.
By that point,
we were hysterical.
-But do you like getting into
character that deep
and going like, "Oh, I can go as
crazy as I want.
I can go to a next level."
-Absolutely, because I always
want people to see me different.
-Yeah.
-You know -- Now, I love
when people love me.
I love when people see me
as maternal and warm and fuzzy.
But there are times when I just
want to scare the
[bleep] out of them.
-Oh, my God.
Okay, there's this Viola,
and there's this Viola.
-Yeah.
-Okay, good.
-I like her.
-Yeah, yeah, we do.
We like her, too.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love you.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Viola Davis in
"The Hunger Games:
The Ballad of
Songbirds and Snakes."
Take a look at this origin...
-[ Laughs ]
How tantalizing to see
all your shining young faces
on this auspicious day.
I am Dr. Volumnia Gaul,
your humble head gamemaker,
in charge of the War Department
and all its affiliated concerns.
I've broken free of my
laboratory today to examine you,
the leaders
of the next generation.
I won't be around forever,
after all.
[ Laughs ]
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I have things I want
to ask about you.
One is your name -- Rachel.
-Yes.
-You got this -- You got your
name from someone very famous.
And am I right?
-You are correct.
I was named after
Rachel Green from "Friends."
-Okay, good. Alright.
That is real?
-That is real.
That is a real fact.
And everybody --
Nobody ever believes me
because they think
that there's no way
I'm young enough
to be named after "Friends."
But --
-No, you were.
-But I am, yeah.
My mom -- They were
going to name me Catherine,
but my older sister's
Jacqueline, and they thought
that might be too confusing
for babies to figure out.
-Yeah. Catherine and Jacqueline.
Yeah.
-Yeah. And, so, yeah,
my mom loved the way it sounded
on "Friends"
for Jennifer Aniston,
and then that was my name.
-I mean, that's a perfect
person to be named --
We love -- Who doesn't love
Jennifer Aniston or Rachel?
-I love Jennifer.
-You could have been
named after the hairstyle.
-I could have been Ross.
-You could have been Ross.
-Who knows?
Yeah, alright.
-All right, why not, right?
-Ross Zegler's got a good name
to it, as well.
-Yeah, right?
-Well, if you want to have
a brother...
I want to talk to you
about this,
because I know you're a big --
You're a big Swiftie.
-Yes.
-And you were at the...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, how cool are you?
-She looks very sad,
but that was just
because I had food poisoning.
-No.
-I did.
-You did not.
You still went to the show.
-Oh, I would not have --
I sold my kidney to be there.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You love her that much?
-I love her so much.
-Back-in-the-day Swiftie?
-Yeah.
From self-titled album,
which we're still waiting
for the re-record of.
[ Cheers and applause ]
See? I found my people
in the audience.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But do you -- Are you
one of those people
at the concerts that yell out,
"Oh, the next song
is going to be this or..."
-Oh, I knew the set list,
I know the callbacks,
and I was waiting
for the secret songs.
-Secret songs.
-Yeah.
-My best friend, Brenna,
had gone in Atlanta,
before the MetLife show,
and I went to MetLife Night 1.
And she said --
-Whoo!
-Thank you.
And she said to my older sister,
Jacqueline,
who I took to the show
with me --
She was like, "Jacqueline,
if they play 'Getaway Car'
or 'Maroon,'
she's on crisis watch."
Not only did she play
"Getaway Car,"
she also played "Maroon."
I was having a mental breakdown
in the audience
at MetLife Stadium.
-I love it.
-Yeah.
And then Ice Spice came out.
And I kept making the joke --
-That's right.
-Exactly.
-I remember that.
-Yeah.
-That was a big deal.
-I was making a joke all night
to the girls behind me.
Wherever they are,
they can attest to it.
I kept making the joke that
Ice Spice was going to come out,
not knowing anything about
that actually happening,
and then it happened.
-Wow. So you should
play the lottery that night.
-Yeah.
-Anything you did came true.
-My Swiftie manifestation
says "Reputation TV" is coming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Right now, let's talk
about "Hunger Games," okay?
"The Ballad of Songbirds --"
Let's focus.
The "Ballad of Songbirds
and Snakes."
-Yes.
-By the way, your character,
Lucy Gray,
sings a lot in the film.
-Yes, she does.
-Which is great.
Which you did live on set.
-I did, yeah.
-You can do it.
You know how to do it.
I mean, I was reading somewhere,
there was, like, inspirations
of Dolly Parton in there.
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, it's -- She's a very --
She's a country, folksy singer.
And, so, Suzanne Collins,
who wrote the book --
she used to be
a country-music deejay.
So she had this, like --
-Oh!
-Yeah. And it's like
she has such
a deep knowledge
of that whole world,
which I really didn't know
too much about.
-I didn't know
she was a country deejay.
-I didn't either.
-That's fascinating.
-Yeah. And so she's obsessed
with Dolly Parton, Patsy Cline,
and then we kind of
based her voice off of that.
-How cool.
-Yeah.
-Well, the soundtrack --
it comes out this Friday,
as well, with you
are featured on it.
-Yeah.
-And Olivia Rodrigo
is featured on the album.
-Yeah.
So everyone's
talking about this.
-Yeah.
-It's already got over
a million streams already.
It's just crushing.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-And you accidentally
started a rumor,
and I thought tonight
would be the perfect night
for you to clear up this rumor.
-It's time to address it.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, I accidentally
started a rumor
that Nicki Minaj
was on the album
for "The Hunger Games:
The Ballad
of Songbirds and Snakes."
-That is not true.
-It's not true. She's not.
She's releasing her album
on Friday, I believe.
But it was one of those things
where there's a character
named Barb Azure in the movie.
And the actress who plays
Barb Azure
has a great sense of humor.
Her name is Honor Gillies.
She's so fantastic.
And posted a video
of Nicki Minaj saying,
"Calling all Barbs"
when she got cast.
And her character plays
the stand-up bass in the movie.
So, obviously, I commented,
"Slapping that super bass,"
as you would.
-Yeah.
-Now, the Barbs got me good.
They were screen-shotting
those comments,
posting them
all over social media,
being like,
"What is mother doing?
They are very, very, very
dedicated and amazing.
I am a Barb.
I love Nicki.
-Yeah.
-But she's not on the album.
But she started playing into it.
She posted a TikTok
with "The Hanging Tree" song,
saying like, "I have something
coming out November 17th."
Like, she knew what
she was doing.
I had no idea what I was doing.
-No idea what she was doing.
No, no. You were just being you
and you go, "I didn't know.
I'd even start this rumor."
-And I didn't know if she
was on the soundtrack,
so I was just
kind of like, "Okay."
-And she's not.
-Okay, good.
I'm glad you said it.
-Just me.
-Yeah. No, good. I'm glad.
It's you and Olivia Rodrigo.
-Yeah.
-We're happy.
-Okay, yeah, we're good.
-Thanks.
-Do we set -- How do we set up
the movie "Hunger Games"?
This is pre-Katniss.
-Set 64 years in the past.
It's been 10 years
since the districts
and The Capitol
have, like, gone to war.
And the Hunger Games have been
going on for 10 years.
-It's a giant,
giant, giant movie.
And I would suggest go see it
in IMAX because it's just a lot.
-And we did film it for IMAX.
It's the craziest experience.
-Enjoy it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rachel Zegler
in "The Hunger Games:
The Ballad of Songbirds
and Snakes."
Take a look.
-♪ This world, it's dark ♪
♪ This world, it's scary ♪
♪ I've taken some,
and so no wonder I'm weary ♪
♪ It's why ♪
♪ I need you ♪
♪ You're as pure as
the driven snow ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪♪
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You started
your career here in New York.
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay, and this is where you --
you auditioned
and booked "Euphoria"?
-Yeah, yeah.
When I was modeling over here,
and then --
and then
it just kind of picked up.
And -- yeah.
-And you've --
you've never acted before.
You were --
-No. No, no.
Acting was not
in the plan at all.
I still -- It's -- I'm like,
I'm just going to ride the wave.
I don't know.
-No, you're really --
-You're fantastic.
-I'm doing it, but...
-Did you --
Did you go to school?
Did you learn how to act?
-Uh, no --
-Or classes?
-Well, they tried to.
They tried to.
[ Light laughter ]
The casting director
set me up with this class,
and I was like 19.
So, I was like,
"Yeah, I'll do it.
I should before
we start filming."
You know?
Have you ever done, like, class?
-Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, it was like --
-Have I ever?
Yes, I don't know.
I might have been
the teacher of that class.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you know.
-Of course, acting
is very, very difficult, yes.
-But it was --
it was a method acting class.
-Oh, that's tricky.
-Which is -- is --
like, it's where --
method acting,
if anyone doesn't know,
it's, like, where you, like,
live as the -- the character.
It's intense.
-Like, what would you do
in class?
-Well, we did have --
what I remember
is this one exercise.
-Uh-huh.
-It's --
It's kind of where you --
you have to put your arms out
and then, like,
roll your shoulders
back like this
and then just go,
"Haaaaahh!"
And you stare at each other
while you do that
until you start crying.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I'm sorry.
Who is this person,
and are they in prison --
whoever taught you this?
[ Laughter ]
What did -- Wait.
So, could I learn?
Could I do an acting class?
-Should we do it?
-We could all do it,
if you want to.
Yeah.
-Yeah, we can all do it.
[ Audience cheers ]
Okay.
-Audience.
-Wait. Wait.
-Where do you want me to go?
-I think we --
we did it standing up
in the class.
-Sure.
-Yeah. Okay.
-Am I going to start crying?
-I don't know.
Like, it's whatever comes up.
-We look right at each other?
-Yeah, yeah, and we look
like this and like this.
And then -- And we roll
our shoulders back.
And then go...
Ready?
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-Okay.
-Haaaaaahh!
-Am I crying?
-Wait. You have --
-I am?
-Oh, it worked.
-It did?
-Yeah. Lookit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're very supportive.
You're very supportive.
-You got glassy.
-I did get
a little glassy there.
-Yeah, I saw it.
-I got a little emotional there.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Yeah.
So, you did that class
for, what, a week?
-I was --
it was a month class, but I...
[ Chuckling ]
It was, like, not okay,
so I dropped out
after the second one.
-Yeah, good.
You don't need it.
-Yeah.
-You're a fantastic actor.
You're great in "Euphoria."
"Hunger Games" --
this is the biggest --
this is going to be
the biggest movie this weekend.
I'm so excited about this.
-Yes!
-I'm so happy we can talk
about movies with actors.
-I know.
-Yes, thank you.
Yeah, it's a big deal.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But I think this is cool,
because you've been a fan
of -- of "The Hunger Games"
since you were a kid.
-Oh, well, I mean,
for Halloween,
I was obsessed with how the
Capitol people were in costumes,
and I made
my own costume once.
Ohhh!
-Oh, bud.
[ Applause ]
-I know.
-This is unbelie--
this is really cool.
-Yeah, I think I was --
-Now you're in "Hunger Games."
-I know. As a Capitol person.
-As a Capitol person!
-It's crazy. It's really --
Yeah, it's -- yeah, crazy.
-Look at you.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations, bud.
Come on, that's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kind of like
not too far off from me.
-Not bad.
-Yeah.
-Tell me who you play.
Tell me who you play.
-I play Tigris.
And she is -- Coriolanus Snow,
who we later know
as President Snow --
she's his cousin,
and they've
been taking care of each other
since they were little --
little children at the Capitol.
-Tigris Snow?
-Tigris Snow.
-I mean, what a great name.
-It's bad--
All the names are so good.
-They are good, but --
-Yeah.
-But you forever will be,
like, "Oh, yeah,
I played Tigris Snow."
-Tiger Snow.
-That feels cool, right?
-It's crazy.
-I want to show
everyone a clip.
Here's Hunter Schafer
in "The Hunger Games: The Ballad
of Songbirds & Snakes."
Take a look.
-Everything is about winning.
If not the games now,
then the crowd.
Lucy Gray won't survive
a minute inside that arena.
So that means we have to make
every second before then count.
We'll get her to sing again.
-I wouldn't sing a note
for you if I was her.
I wouldn't do anything at all,
unless I could trust you.
-She's District, Tigris.
She knows we hate her,
and she wants us dead.
How am I supposed to get her
to trust me?
-Imagine it was your name
that they pulled
and you had been ripped
from your home.
I'd just want to know that
somebody still cared about me
out here.
Don't discount her just
because she's District, Corio.
You might have more in common
with her than you think.
[ Dramatic music intensifies ]
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hunter Schafer, everybody!